اه هذا مو خرجت مكالمات هاتفيه فيما بعد
ويبدو انه اراد ان يعود وقيل له لا مستوى
هذه السنه
وانا سمعت التسجيلات بطبيعه الحال ايييي
كل ما يمكن ان اقول ان الصوت صوت رئيس فقط
لا لم يكن بالامكان ان يعني يكون ذلك
مقبولا بالنسبه الى التونسيين او الى
النظام الحالي اذا اذا ما قدمناه وتعهدات
بعد ممارسه العمل السياسيه
يرفضون عودته باي صفه من الصفات
يعني اصحاب توجهات اسلاميه
من اصناف مختلفه حتى يعني همم
ربما سيكون متضررا من عودته
ولكن
[موسيقى]
المطروح هو
انه عندما ننظر الى نقل جثمان ااا من
يتجرا بس يقول نقل جثمان من البقيعه خرجوا
من ذلك المكان
المقدس عند المسلمين
لرئيس سابق
وتذكار له في بلاده هذا هو المطلوب بعدين
قال الجثمان ونقله للعائله كلمته كلمتها
ولل الظروف
الموضوع موضوعنا هو ان بان عليه همم
23 سنه من الحكم
بحكوماته
بالكفاءات التي كانت من حوله
بسيسات التي اعتمدها
كانت تونس تعيش يوميا حياتها اليوميه
اللاعب الحريات وعلى التعدديه ولا
انتخابات لكن كانوا يعيشوا خير في ظروف
ايسر
تعانيه الاسره التونسيه اليوم
اقتصاديا توقف الاستثمارات
نسبه المديونيه التي دفعت الى السماء
المرحله بتاع الشيطان وهو عمل لها وسرقها
وكسرها وكذا يعني
اثق في العداله التونسيه لان ما زال فيها
رجالا
يؤتمنون على حقوق الناس
العائله كما كان يسمى حول التقييد الامني
حول التعذيب والى ما هنا